the a stadium and what the legislature
is doing about it topping our news on
this Memorial Day good evening to you
thanks for joining us I'm Brian Loftus
lawmakers in Carson City they're in
committee as we speak hearing public
comment on the bill to fund the A's new
baseball stadium our 8 news now
investigator Kyle Payne joining us in
the studio as he is closely following
next steps Brian the hearing started
about an hour ago in Carson City we're
expecting to hear from the public there
as well as here in Las Vegas online and
over the phone it's happening during a
hearing in the Senate finance committee
and the assembly Ways and Means
Committee this marks the first time
lawmakers have officially addressed the
public funds lia's are asking for to
build their new stadium on this trip
SB 509 otherwise known as the funding
bill outlining how the state and Clark
County will pay to build this thirty
thousand seat 1.5 billion dollar Stadium
where the Tropicana Hotel sits Senate
Bill
509 this joint hearing of the state
senate finance and assembly Ways and
Means committees is the first we've
heard from lawmakers a new ballpark for
the Athletics will be a publicly owned
Community Asset that will continue to
support the state's primary economic
engine
and it will house a major league
baseball team at The Residence at Clark
County could rally behind and this was
also the people's chance to officially
weigh in on public funds the A's are
looking for to build the stadium which
they expect to have views of the Las
Vegas Strip the A's are expected to
spend more than a billion dollars and
they want 380 million including 180
million from the state and 145 million
from Clark County that money will come
from bonds that the county plans to
repay using taxes from the area in and
around the ballpark a couple thousand
people have made their opinions known on
the legislature's website and so far by
the looks of it public opinion is
overwhelmingly against this bill now all
of a sudden at the last minute of the
legislature they spring this plan to
spend 500 million dollars on a without
any proof that it will benefit the
community to that it just infuriates me
I understand the opposition to what
people are considering to be a gift of
taxable funds I understand that
completely what they're not seeing is
the full picture of this in the revenues
that will be created
that's an A's fan at the Las Vegas
portion of this hearing once this
funding bill gets out of committee the
rest of the legislature will get a look
at it it's all happening quickly because
the legislative session in Carson City
ends one week from today June 5th and
lawmakers have a lot of other business
to take care of before then if they
don't they might have to call a special
session Brian